hello welcome to the second part of my
tutorial about logic and computer
science
with a strong bias towards automate in
the first part i discussed
the model checking problem for a fixed
structure m
so this was the problem where we have a
fixed structure and we want to decide
its theory
meaning the formulas that are true in it
and
we discuss both the first order theory
and the mso theory
in this second part uh which i will do
now
i will discuss the satisfiability
problem so we are given an mso formula
we're not given the model and we want to
know if the form is true in that model
and when i'm discussing this problem uh
maybe
there are two questions to ask so first
of all what kind of models do i care
about
and what kind of logic so the original
version of this problem is uh the what
is is
and so it is the logic is first order
logic
and the models are all possible models
so we want to know
if a formula is true in some models so
dually we want to know if the formula is
true in all models it's the same
decision problem
and this is equivalent uh to uh thanks
to the completeness problem
theorem of first order logic this is the
same problem as deciding if a problem is
if your
formula is is provable uh so you will
find this in
uh in hilbert ackermann's book
from 1928 uh which asks
uh uh under the name of the tridunch
problem
as a problem of giving a formula to
decide if it is
equivalent to the uh identity formula
the true formula so and this
is uh famously undecidable
which was proved in 1936 by
independently by church and turing uh
introducing the
the notion of undecidability and and and
also of
of decidability in the process
when a gilbert and ackermann asked about
whether or not a formula is true they
meant it true in all models including
infinite ones
but in in computer science a a a natural
question would be
if a formula is true in our finite
models
and this problem was it was treated
first discussed
by trachtenbrot who who proved that it
is also
undecidable maybe uh let me give you a
a presentation of uh well a rough sketch
of of what uh trashton brought
how traffic brought uh how traffic's
problem is
undecidable about uh being true in all
finite models
uh because this will be uh play a role
later on
in in this tutorial so
the picture is this for every turing
machine you can think of the
computation of the turing machine as a
grid
where the rows describe configurations
of the turing machine and
and consecutive every two consecutive
roles are related by a one
step relation of the turing machine and
using this description
uh you can uh write a first
order sentence of first order logic for
a turing machine
which inputs a model that describes such
a grid
which describes a computation so you
have to say how a grid describes a
computation so that the underlying set
is going to be
something like elements of the grid and
there's going to be some extra
structure which is used to uh describe
the
the computation of the turing machine
such as for every
node of the grid you have to say what is
the color of it now so
what is the state of the turing machine
and then you have to have
the the the the the grid structures of
the the
neighborhood relation so that the left
right
and up down moves but all of this can be
easily encoded in first order logic
and and hence you can write the formula
such which is true if and only if the
input describes a
a grid which would describes and
a halting computation of the tournament
and this formula is true in some finite
model if and only if the machine holds
so uh using this idea you can uh show
that problem
b also is a sentence true in all finite
models it is an undecidable problem
and a similar thing works for problem a
so the original incidence problem
but we have to be a little bit careful
because the kind of undecidable you get
is is different
because for problem b uh whether or not
a a a formula is true in all finite
models is
is co-recursively innumerable because a
a a
a model is a finite witness for not
being true
in all models a model a counter example
so you have a finite counter example
while in problem a the
complexity class is complementary
because a finite witness for being there
is a finite witness for being true
namely a proof
and and therefore the problem is is
recursively
innumerable but apart from these
differences the
undecidability proof looks very similar
just have to be careful about the exact
kind of halting problem that you encode
so this means that that that the
satisfiability problem or or the
validity which is the
well the complementary problem so there
is equity decidable
they are undesirable both for finite
models and
arbitrary models so in this sense uh
we have to impose some restrictions and
there are two kinds of restrictions that
you might want to impose the first one
is you
restrict the class of models and this
will be the
kind of restriction that i will be
discussing in most detail in my
tutorial and the second restriction of
course
restrict the formulas so you would say i
don't want to decide satisfiability for
every formula but only for some formulas
and if you choose your restriction well
the problem might become decidable
i will begin with axis 1 and i will
spend the most
time on it because it is the one where
automata turned out to be most useful
and let me begin with a very special
case and
as it will turn out it's actually
roughly the only thing you can do
which is uh the case when i care only
about
models which are similar to words and
trees
so how does this work uh you can
think of a finite word over some
alphabet
as a model as a structure so the
underlying set
in the model is the positions of the
word and it is equipped with
with the order on the positions and and
for every uh
letter in the input alphabet you have a
unary predicate which selects positions
with that label
once you have viewed a word as a
a model then you can send a first order
queries to that word and
and and get a yes or no answer so for
example
if we take the formula which says for
every position x there is a position y
which is a greater or equal and has
label a
well that means that the letter last
letter in the word has labeled a
so this particular formula if if if you
only care about models which
correspond to words then it's going to
be true in those words where the last
position has label a
and let's say that our alphabet is a b
then this is going to be
the language a plus b star a so it's a
regular language
so this particular formula it defines a
regular language
but in in general every formula of
say first order logic it will define for
you a language of finite words the
the words in which the corresponding
model satisfies the formula
and uh it turns out that
you will only get regular language so
it's not a coincidence and in fact this
will also be true
if you extend your logic not to be not
just first order logic but also to be
a monadic second order so this is a
theorem which is uh roughly speaking uh
uh
it was it's the one that was proved by
uh by bihi el got andrasten buttons
first in the first
part of my lecture which is that
the regular languages are exactly the
same ones that you can define in monadic
second order logic
and the right to left implication was
the one that was
proved in when i would discuss the
elgato tragedy theorem but the opposite
inclusion was also proved by them
in the original papers is is kind of
straightforward
so how do you transform a finite
automaton into
an equivalent formula of mso monadic
secondary logic
well it's it's very easy all you have to
do is you just write
it should be easier you have to write a
formula which says the automaton accepts
the word so let's see that formula in
action and this will allow you
to to get some get used a bit to to to
mso so i suppose that i have a regular
language
and i want to prove that it can be
defined in mso how do you do that
well assume that the automaton has a n
transitions it's a finite optimization
many
transitions and what i will write here i
will just write off the formula
which just using the syntax of mso
it will say that the automaton has at
least one accepting run
so how do you do that well you're going
to say that there exists
sets x1 up to xn so each set corresponds
to a transition so suppose we have
numbered the transitions
and then you say that these sets
describe a run
you say that well first of all you say
that for every position x
there is exactly one transition used
which means that there is exactly one of
the sets x1 up to xm
which selects at that position so there
is at least one set and then there is no
other set uh here the disjunction ranges
over a finite many
possible choices for the transition then
you say that the
first position is selected by a
transition where the
source state is an initial one so you
say that for every position x if it's
the first position
well this is this can be written a first
of x can be written as there is no
position which is a
strictly before then you say that there
exists a transition
such that which labels that position but
you only
look at those trans transitions where
the source state is one of the initial
states of the output
then you say that for every two
consecutive positions again x plus one
equals y can be easily expressed using
the order
uh uh you say that the transition in a
position
x i and in the next one they have to
agree on their joint state so the target
state of i
i is equal to the source rate of j which
is expressed using a
finite disjunction over the set of
transitions
and then finally say that the last
position uses a state
whose target is is one of the accepting
or final states in the automata
so this is just a straightforward form a
formula
uh formalization of the semantics of an
automaton
and it is going to work for all kinds of
automata uh such as
automata on the mega words or raven
automata on
infinite trees or parity automaton
infinite trees
because you can just quantify over the
objects which are
used in the definition of the semantics
of the output
and therefore we know that regular and
mso
are the same thing so this was actually
the main result of of of the papers by
bihi elgat
and krakengrot in the late 50s and
as a corollary uh the problem
of given an msl sentence which uses the
order and the labels and you want to
know
if the formula is true that these ones
finite well this problem is decidable
because uh what you do is you
take the mso sentence you translate it
into an
automaton using the fact that all of the
constructs of logic can be
implemented on automata although with
exponential and multiple exponential
cost and then
in the end you get an automaton which uh
this recognizes the same except the same
words as the sentence and then
you can just check if that automaton is
not empty by uh by checking if
some accepting state is is reachable
from the initial state
uh so that's uh that's the famous
logic and automata connection
it it also works in in many other setups
so for example
for omega words it's the same idea once
you have shown that
the appropriate automata that you're
dealing with are closed under
all operations in logic so boolean
operations and projection
and disclosure is effective then you can
translate every
uh mso sentence in
into an accurate automaton and check
that automation for emptiness and
for automata emptiness is easy to be
decidable and similar ideas work for
infinite trees now
here i i state the satisfiability
problem
as a separate problem problem from model
checking from the one that was discussed
before
this is a little bit inaccurate because
for the particular logic that i'm
discussing here so uh mso
the the the lines are kind of blurred
between
the problem of is the formula true in in
in
natural numbers for example in beauty's
case and is it true in at least one
in one labeling of natural numbers and
why is that
well uh suppose that let's consider
omega words so the satisfiability
problem would be something like
we are given a formula phi which
describes uh a set
of of words over some alphabet say a b
and then the moral checking problem that
the original one
discussed by by b he would be uh you you
have the natural numbers
and no labels and you want to know the
formula is true then you can reduce
satisfiability to model checking
by just guessing uh encoding the the
label of your
hypothetical word w using a set well
let's say two sets
the set of positions we have label a and
the set of positions would have label b
so what they're it's really one set
because
a a and b are mutual complements and
therefore the satisfiability problem
can be reduced to the model checking
problem
and conversely of course model checking
is the same as satisfiability if you
just assume that your alphabet has one
letter so the natural numbers you order
correspond the unique word over one
letter alphabet
so because mso can quantify over
over labors satisfiability and model
checking are kind of the same problem
and this is also true for infinite trees
so
if you look at raven's original problem
which is deciding whether or not an mso
sentence is true
in the unlabeled infinite tree then this
is
the same decision problem as checking if
a formula with with some which describes
labeled trees is true in at least one
labeled tree
uh because you can use mso to to
quantify set quantification to to guess
the labels of your
hypothetical model so satisfiability and
model checking in mso
if the underlying structure is is fixed
to be uh
say the omega the the natural order
natural numbers in the case of omega
words and the raven's tree in the case
of infantries
then uh a satisfiability and mobile
checking are the same
problem because you can push the the
the labeling of your hypothetical word
into the logic
but this perspective that uh you have a
language and you can define it in a
logic
but or an alternative you can describe
it in automata it's it
it has proved to be a very fruitful and
we'll see examples that of that in a
moment for other
structures uh such as such as graph
but before i continue with uh uh graphs
uh i'd like to mention an alternative
perspective on these results
where instead of using logic
or automata we use algebra
and algebra here means semi groups or
mods
so ammonoid it's
like a group but it doesn't need to have
inverses
so formally speaking ammonoid
is a is an algebraic structure which
consists of an underlying set
which is equipped with a binary
concatenation operation which is
associative so
it doesn't matter in which order you
concatenate
things you always get the same result
and it has
a neutral element for concatenation
which i write here by epsilon but
usually it's written by one
uh in the group fashion a semi group is
like a monoid but you don't require the
existing
of a neutral element and you can use
monoi to
recognize languages how do you do that
well we say that the language is
recognized by
a monoid or or in in particular a finite
monologue
if there is a function which is a monoid
from the words to the monoid which
gives you all the information you need
to know with respect to the language in
other words if you know the
image of the function then you know
whether or not the word
belongs to the language so here m is
required to be a monarch homomorphism
and what does that mean
well first of all observe that the
domain of the function
sigma star is a monoid because words
with concatenation and the empty world
are among and monarch homomorphism is a
function
between two monoids which is consistent
with the monoid operations meaning that
the empty word is mapped to the empty
world the neutral element is mapped to
the neutral element
and also it's compatible with
concatenation so if you concatenate and
then apply the homomorphism or you first
apply the homomorphism and then you
concatenate
you get the same result so this gives
you the definition of a language which
is
recognized by a monoid or a finite
monolith
and then as you can see in the top right
corner of the slide
regular uh languages as defined say by
finite automata are the same thing
as regular languages recognized by
finite monarchs
so let me give a quick overview of the
very straightforward proof of this
so let's go first from monoi to automata
so suppose that i have a language that
is recognized by a finite monoid
and this can be depicted on the diagram
as follows
so it's there's the words and then you
map them
via homomorphisms to the monoid and then
recognizability says that
in order to know the answer for the
language l the yes no answer
you you can do this by passing through
the homomorphism and getting some
accepting set to give you a yes or no
answer depending on the elements of the
finite moment
this diagram is not going to be useful
for the proof but it's just uh to
visualize
what it means to be recognized by a
finite moment
and then based on this homomorphism and
the accepting set
we can easily create a deterministic
finite automaton
where the states are the elements of the
monoid the initial state is the empty
element of the month
the transition function it inputs a
state which is a monoid element
m and then input letter a and it just
appends
in the monoid the value of the input
letter
and then you have the accepting states
which are the same
as in the monolith now uh this you can
uh you
easily see that the state of this
automaton after reading an input block
word is the same thing as the image of
that input word under the
homomorphism eight and therefore the uh
if you use the same accepting states in
the
automaton as in demonic we will
recognize the same language
maybe it is useful to to to to visualize
what happens in this automaton
so if you read a a word then the the
value in the monoid
that that that you're going to compute
by the automaton
consists of you start in the empty uh
where the initial state and then you
keep on applying
uh the the letters of the of the input
word
and if you think of it as the paris tree
uh the type of monoid operations that
you're going to be applying
as illustrated in this little tree it is
going to be a special tree which is
has like one big uh left
path where the letters are are appended
to it in
in the order of the input word however
ammonoid
and this is what makes the difference
between a monolith and an automaton
the monoid allows you also to parse the
input word in
other ways than the one which is used by
an automaton
and this is the difference between one
and automata that monoids
allow for a different parse tree than
the the the the unbalanced
left to right uh tree that i have done
here for example you can have a balanced
tree of depth logarithmic in the in a
then for the input world and you can
have a
tree which is unbalanced to the right
and so on and this uh
the fact that the monoi is prepared to
accept different parts
uh parse trees of the input world is
what's
responsible for the the niceness of this
model and
and it's its advantages that i will
discuss because later on
uh so that proves that every finite mono
it can be transformed in automaton uh
well it's the same underlying set so
it's it's a linear transformation
now let's go from a finite automaton to
a monolith and here the transformation
is going to be exponential so there is a
cost
of going to a moment and this is also
very straightforward
so imagine you have a language that's
recognized by say a deterministic finite
automaton of stage q
so the homomorphism that we're going to
use is the function which maps an input
word
to its state transformation which is a
function from states to states so the
elements of the monolith are going to be
functions from states to states
and therefore if the automaton has n
states then the corresponding monoid
will have n to the power
of n states well maybe slightly less
because not all
state transformations needs to be used
by the automaton
and then you can easily figure out that
the
set of state transformations is ammonoid
with
the monoid operation being a composition
of functions and
the empty world being empty neutral
element
being the identity state transformation
and also that the function h
is a is is indeed a monolithic
homomorphism
and uh and therefore uh we have just
created a homomorphism
into a finite one which recognizes the
same language
the accepting set is going to be those
state transformations which map the
initial state of the automaton
to uh some accepting say state uh this
trans
this construction is is exponential as i
mentioned
and actually also works for
non-deterministic automata
so if you uh uh you you can use instead
of the set of
functions from state to states you can
use the set of binary relations
between states and this will correspond
to non-deterministic alternate and then
monoid operation is going to be
composition of binary relations
so now we have seen that automata and
monoids
are the same and it's a relatively
straightforward construction
and uh why am i telling you about
but enough of advertising for monitors
uh let's let's continue with our story
where we show that uh
logic has the same expressive power as
various kinds of automata or
hormones so uh as i said uh
for words and trees you can translate
mso formulas
and also the first order special case
into corresponding automata and then use
automata emptiness procedures to check
if the formulas are satisfied in at
least one
model but uh what about going beyond
words and trees what about things which
are not necessarily you know
cannot not obviously be a process by an
automaton
and in if we study that then it will
turn out that the natural
concept that appears and the one that i
think
is useful to know is something called
tree with so let's move into that
direction
uh so uh we
so far we have used mso to describe the
properties of
of of words for example finite words by
uh
viewing a a word as a as a model where
the
underlying set of the model is is the
positions of the word they're ordered
and they have labors
you can do the same thing for graphs say
undirected graphs just to uh for focus
attention and then uh the
one way to mod view a graph as a model
is that the underlying set
is the vertices and the edges and there
is one binary relation which tells you
that a vertex is incident
to an edge there there are other choices
you could for example say that the
underlying set is the vertices only and
there's a binary
relation uh which tells you that there's
an edge from v
to w i will use the incidence model and
and this this
actually is it plays a certain role
which i will uh
describe later on so if you think about
mso formulas or even first order
formulas as describing
properties of graphs in this way then
the satisfiability problem is
undecidable so it is
undecidable given a first order sentence
which say uses the incident relation to
decide if it is true in at least one
graph
uh it's uh you have two variants of the
problem uh
uh whether you ask for finite graphs or
not necessary finite plus in both cases
is
undecidable and the reason is as in the
incidence problem
is that you know you can have grids uh
grid-like graphs which which describe
the
computations of a turing machine and
therefore satisfiability
is the same thing as the halting problem
and this is uh so as i said it's it's
for
finite or not necessarily finite graphs
and the same works
either when you use the encoding that i
chose whether it's vertices and edges
and an incidence relation or if you use
alternative choice
it's the same thing so generally
speaking first already for first order
logic you don't need mso for that
the satisfiability problem is
undecidable but
as i said it is because of grids so
let's have a look at those
so when you uh when you show that the
satisfiability problem is
is undecidable the kind of graphs that
you want your formula to define
are going to look sort of like this so
if your logic is mso
then you can uh write the formula
which inputs a graph checks that it is
indeed a grid this can be uh defined
and then once it knows that it's a grid
then it uses the the sets to color
the positions of the grid to get uh to
describe
a computation of a turing machine so as
as long as you're going to have uh grids
then you're going to be undecidable
but what about what graphs that
kind of look like trees so we know
already that if you just restrict to
literally trees
then uh by rabin's theorem and just a
very special case of
raven's theorem as long as you care for
uh for finite trees
then the mso satisfiability is going to
be decidable
but what about grass which are kind of
trees
but they're uh they're not literally
trees but they they they
their trees up to some small changes
there's one in the picture i mean don't
try to understand it it's not meant to
be
it's just meant to be a graph which
looks like a tree but it's not
literally a tree and it turns out that
there is actually a way of
of defining what it means for a graph to
look like a tree and this way is very uh
productive because it allows us to
recover the automata
method to to to uh on graphs and to get
satisfied with the results so uh this
this this notion is called tree with and
i will define it here
uh using a sort of logical approach
which is which is inspired by why
crusades
the classical 3d composition terminology
so i will use to define tree with a
notion of a graph with ports
so a graph with ports is just a graph
with distinguished vertices so a subset
of the vertices
are distinguished and uh i assume that
they're numbered so this port 1.2.3 and
so on
and then i say that a graph has a tree
with k so it's a number
if the graph can be constructed using
a graph with ports such that at every
moment you have
at most k plus one ports and you use the
operations that i would describe
below the k plus one is just a
traditional choice uh which is made so
that
trees have three with one and not three
with uh
zero so not treat two
uh so what are the operations well the
first operation that you have
on graphic reports is that you can start
with any
any graph where all vertices are ports
uh so
if you are allowed to have at most k
plus one parts then you're allowed to
start with any graph where all vertices
are imports and therefore there's at
most k plus 1 vertices
the second operation that you're allowed
to implement on on graphs
with ports is a forget operation which
inputs a
graph of parts and a a chosen part which
you intend to forget
and then the output of the
forget operation is is is the same
graph with parts as you got on the input
except that the chosen part is no longer
a part
so we have one less port in the output
but
the vertices and edge relations are the
same and
finally there is a fuse operation which
inputs
two graphs with ports and a partial
eject
bijection between the ports which says
which
which parts are supposed to be
identified and then on the output you
just
join the two graphs of ports into a
single graph with port and
the parts which were paired by the
bijection become the same ports
now there are two ways of understanding
what i wrote here fuse
in one case uh you require that the
bijection is also a partial isomorphism
so if in the left graph
there is an edge between two vertices
and they are
mapped by that a bijection to some two
per verb vertices or parts in the right
graph then there should also be an edge
and conversely so
uh so you're only allowed to fuse graphs
where the bijection
preserves the the graph structure that's
a variant one
and variant two is that you don't make
this assumption and you allow the
bijection to not preserve the graph
structure and then in the output graph
uh you just have an edge if
either on the left or on the right you
have an edge it turns out that the
two fuse operations are equivalent in
the same sense that they need to the
same notion of attributes
uh so it doesn't really matter which one
w which one
you use and uh let me give you and now
an example of a graph of small tree with
so uh here's a proof that the cycle of
length eight has trued
two so what i have to do to show this is
i have to construct it
using graphs with at most three parts so
what i do is i start with this small
graph
which like a line which has three
vertices all of which are distinguished
so that's a constant the legitimate
constant
now i can forget the middle vertex on
the path and this way i get a path
which has only the two endpoints are
parts
now on this side i can construct a a
different
graph like the one here so it's a
one path and one vertex and now i can
fuse them
by identifying uh
some of the vertices so the two the
vertices in in the
on the right in both graphs and this way
i get a path
of length four uh with uh well one
vertex being uh
not a port i can forget it and this way
i've generated a path
of length four and actually i could
continue like this by just adding edge
by edge by edge by edge
uh vertices to to this path uh to get a
a a a path of arbitrary length uh so
let's continue maybe for
for one more step so i can
add one more edge here on the right and
then
i can fuse them and and now i have a
path of length five
and let's let's stop here and let's
create a half of length
five at the bottom and let's fuse them
and this way i close the cycle
and now i can forget all of the ports
and this way i have just
generated a cycle of length eight
and in fact uh you can do this for the
cycles of any length
and therefore all cycles have a three
with two
all trees have three with one and uh
every graph has a sum tree with so for
example if a graph has a k vertices then
you can construct it
uh using at most k points and and
therefore every uh there's a
by just using a single constant and
therefore every finite graph has
true at most k minus 1 but typically
it's going to be
less so this is a tree with is is our
formalization
of a graphs which are similar to trees
so the graph
that you see on the right in this
picture here can actually
be defined using at most
three points freeport at any given
moment and and so it has
a three with two
so uh what is the uh what is the
the advantage of treats
well you can show this was observed by
cursel
that the following problem is decidable
so for bounded treat if you have a pound
on the tree with an msl sentence
and you want to know if phi is true in
some graph let's assume finite graphs
here but it would also work for infinite
graphs of
what count of the infinite graph of of
truth
at most k and the proof is kind of
simple
uh it's as follows so if you have a
width k 3d composition so it's a it's
like a term which is built using the
operations on on graphs with
at most k plus 1 ports you can view it
as a tree
i uh where the nodes are the operations
the
the the fuse nodes i have two children
the forget nodes have one child and the
constant nodes have zero children
and uh and then there's like finitely
many labels because uh
how many forget operations you have
where you have one forget operation for
every port that you intend to forget
and then you have uh a slightly more
fuse operations because you need to
describe the bijection but it's still a
finite number of bijections so you can
view a width k decomposition as a finite
tree
and now it turns out that ms flow is
strong enough
to extract a graph from its 3d
composition
in the following sense that if you have
an
mso formula on a graph and then uh
you uh you can convert it into an
alternative the
black file is the one on graphs then you
can convert it into an
alternative red phi which works on trees
which has the following property
that if this is for fixed k uh
that if you're given a a width k
3d composition then you can either run
you can either compute the underlying
graph and then apply the black formula
or you can just directly on the tree
which describes 3d composition you can
run the red formula and it will give you
the same result
and the idea is very simple because
vertices of the underlying graph they
correspond sort of to
nodes it will leaves of the 3d
composition
and then this can be all defined inside
mso and therefore since the red formula
can also be computed the black formula
is true in some
graph of tree with a k if and only if
the the red formula is true in some
tree here if they were talking about if
finite trees uh finite graphs which are
where the
3d compositions are finite and deciding
if
a mso formula is true in some finite
tree
is a decidable problem as i mentioned
before but thanks to raven's theorem but
actually much less all you need to do is
have automaton finite trees
which are kind of straightforward and
all of the difficult parts of raymond's
theorem don't appear there so uh
for every k there's a there's an
algorithm which inputs a tree width and
the sentence and tells you if a graph is
is true
in a a if formula is true in the graph
of that tree of k and of course as i
mentioned before
if k is not given uh and you're just
asking for some finite graph
then then the problem is decidable
but you might say well this is a little
bit ad hoc maybe there are some
other restrictions on on graphs uh which
which also ensure that mso uh satisfied
between slide
i mean one obvious parameter is k is the
size of a graph and then of course
deciding if an mso sentence is true in
some graph of size at most k
it is easily decidable because you can
enumerate four finitely many graphs
but it turns out that true it is in fact
the only thing that you can do
well the the best thing that you can do
and this is a result
of a the graph miners project of
robertson and seymour
so a deep theorem of robertson seymour
tells you
that if you have a graph with large tree
width then
that graph will contain a large grid as
a miner
now i don't want to go into the details
of that
definitely not into the proof but maybe
just i
record to you what is the notion of a
graph minor
you a minor of a graph is obtained by
eliminating vertices and contracting
edges and uh now the notion of a minor
is such that you can use you can it can
be formalized in mso
so if you have a a property
of graphs definable and mso
by a former sa5 then also the property
some minor satisfies phi can also be
defined in mso and so for example if phi
says that
the graph describes a grid which
represents a holding computation of a
turing machine
then you can lift that to minors by
saying i contain
a large grid which describes a halting
computation of a turing machine
and since every graph with large trees
will contain such a grid by by the grid
theorem of robinson
seymour you will be able to isolate
this computation inside any graph of
large tree
and and therefore this is a something
that was observed by
cesa if a class of graphs has unbounded
tribute
then mso satisfiability over that class
is going to be undecidable so the
problem
given an msl sentence phi is it true in
some
graph from the class c this is going to
be an undecidable problem so
mso satisfiability is decidable if your
graph class is is all graphs of truth
most k
and it's a undecidable if it has
unbounded
and this this uh so so so we have a
pretty good understanding
of what makes this mso satisfied with
decidable or undecidable on graphs it is
treated
now there's this alternative red choice
where you describe a graph by uh
having just the vertices uh in the
underlying set and the relation being
edges uh this for first order logic it
doesn't really matter because
uh you can if you want to quantify over
an edge then you can just add a over a
pair of vertices
over two vertices for mso it does make a
difference
because if your underlying set is just
the vertices it's not clear how to
quantify over a set of edges and in fact
you you cannot do it and
and and mso is less expressive over the
red
model but there is a notion of a tree
width which is applicable to the red
model uh red description and it is
something called
clique width but i do not have uh time i
don't want to go
into liquid in this particular tutorial
so we'll just skip
so that that is the axis of restricting
the models i was focusing
here on monadic second order logic and
here we have a very good and deep
understanding of what goes on
what makes the logic undecidable is
unbounded through it if you bound it
it's decidable if you don't it's not
now in my tutorial i do not plan
to discuss in much detail the second
axis which is somehow maybe the more
classical axis probably because the
second axis is somehow less related to
automata
but i will say nonetheless uh just a few
words about it
uh at the end of this part
so how can you restrict the logic uh
uh i uh let's let me focus here
mainly on on fragments of first order
logic
not mso uh because this has been a very
classical topic
like since the beginning since since
then jaidum's problem was introduced
people asked
well how can you restrict first order
logic so that it is decidable so what i
would like to mention on this slide
is just uh three fragments of first
order logic
which are
entry points into into interesting uh uh
topics
uh uh about algorithms for logic so the
the first uh fragment well i'll start
off with a very baby
example is they consider uh formulas of
first order logic
which are just purely existential which
means you have a prefix of existential
quantifiers and then you have a
quantifier-free formula
well this is easily seen to be decidable
because if all of your quantifiers are
at the beginning and their existential
then if you take a model of this formula
then you can keep only the elements of
the underlying set which are
captured by the existential quantifiers
and uh delete all the others
and and and therefore uh uh you if the
formula has a
model then it has a model where the
number of elements is
uh the number of of uh at most the
number of the quantifiers and
and hence it it can be described uh say
by uh the problem is
is in np and it's easily seen to be uh
np complete
so that's a very baby example and uh
then uh this type of reasoning has been
studied since the beginning
and there are famous
examples of restrictions on first order
logic
which lead to a decidable
satisfiability question so this has been
actually quite well classified so if you
uh if you of think about your uh
your type of classification is what is
the quantifier prefix that you can allow
well exist star is an obvious one but
you can also
show exists star for all star this was
done by bernie sanders in 1928
and another example is the ackermann
class where
you have only existential quantifiers at
the beginning with one exception which
is the universal quantifier
and this is also decidable and the kind
of quantifier prefixes that lead to
decidability or not are
are well classified and then if you want
to investigate more about this
have a look at the book by berger gretel
and greg
so that's one direction i just i take a
formula first order logic
i assume that all of the quantifiers are
at the beginning and then i add
what is the kind of quantifier pattern
here's a different and also quite
influential
restriction on first order logic which
has been studied
a lot it is a two variable first order a
lot
so this is first order logic where you
have to use two variables but
you're allowed to re-quantify a variable
so your variables are x and y
but you can quantify it again and again
and again so
to see an example here is a formula
which says
that the relation r contains the
directed path of length four
because you say there's an edge rx and y
and then you say
that from the target of that edge y you
can continue it to some
x and then you can continue some y and
so on so this way
you can say that there's a path of
length 4 or 10 or so and
so you can do things which are not uh uh
not uh
you can have uh well arbitrary large
formulas which
describe some things and it was this
this this logic was
proved to be decidable in in 1975 and
actually it's been
studied quite intensively
also the last two decades and the kind
of methods that you apply here
are are counting methods so things like
um
linear equations because if you uh if
you analyze the logic gate
it allows you to tell things like
there's then the number of a's is equal
to the number of
number of vertices in with some color is
equal to the number of vertices some
other color
and then you can describe things like
that but it turns out that not much more
so um this kind of counting methods
applied to to variable first or logic
have been studied quite a lot and
and there's going to be a forthcoming
book by ian hartman
on the topic one last fragment that i
like to mention and it is because
it has a certain kind of connection with
automata is something called
the guarded fragment which was
introduced by andre kavantim and nemeti
now i describe it in a certain way it's
it i don't think is the original
intention of the authors and it's as
follows you
define the guarded fragment to be a
restriction on the shape of first order
formulas which is designed
so that if your formula has at least one
model then it also has a model which has
a small truth and the truth being like
at most
the size of them that's the formula or
or maybe uh more precisely at most
the the arity of the of the
of the relations used by by the formula
and uh well if you have this target in
mind you can you can
come up eventually with a syntactic
restriction which guarantees this
and then once you have done this then uh
satisfiability for your logic is going
to be decidable
uh because uh checking if a formula of
first order logic and even
mso is true in a graph of of known three
which is a decidable problem
as i mentioned before and this fragment
has been also studied quite intensively
and it
turns out to be quite robust and and
and you can generalize it you can add
fixed points and things like that
and it continues to be decidable and uh
all the time thanks to this treat uh
property
but as i said uh my main focus in this
tutorial
is to describe uh uh logics which are
decided by the automata method
and so i will not uh go too much into
uh the classical choice of restricting
first order
logic and so we have
come to the end of the second part where
i decide if a formula is true in some
model and and the main kinds of special
case that i was carrying here about is
that
i care about formulas whose models can
be described by automata
[Music]
they're recognized by automata and
therefore the satisfiability problem
can be reduced to automaton emptiness
and in the last
part of my lecture part three which will
be a separate lecture
i will discuss the variant of the model
checking problem
where i fix the formula and then in my
my input is is the model and this will
be a part where
i will have a less of an automata
emphasis thank you
you